it's crazy that the word is available
for sale
and
and i'm kind of all over the place here
um
and i'm not defending anybody for saying
it i mean it's
you know you hear it i hear it all the
time i hear it all the time you hear it
from people in these days when i when i
was young you would hear it
well i guess i would hear when i was
young growing up from people that were
racist and i would hear it from music
you know nwa and
and so it's weird because it's like a
word that's used in hip-hop culture
you know with the a at the end
and um
and so it's just it's it's interesting
and i don't want to be afraid to like
think about things you know
but one thing that really made me upset
about uh
about the n-word is
the way that media outlets cover it
and
the way that media outlets cover it so
somebody says it
right
they take it
and they make articles
that say at the top of the and these are
outlets that would never even probably
cover the person that if there's a
famous person that says it
you know uh you can be a white dude in a
starter jacket and say it all day you
could be six nine and say it all day you
know
but if you're popular and you say it the
media they cramp down on you
and what gets me um
is that
they use it the media puts inward
in the
title
of articles
so they get you to go click on it
and then then you're reading the article
you're watching it or whatever it is
so they are making money
off of it
and man that burns me up
to think that
because then you and i bet if you follow
the companies
who is who's
who are earning money from the clicks
and the
people watching or reading
i bet it leads right to white pockets i
guarantee you that
so
man it's just crazy that people that
would never even cover this artist
at all or this celebrity at all
suddenly they're writing articles that
are clickable
that they're making money on
so they're basically making money off of
the n-word
they're making money off of it
and man that really i mean that just
yeah man that just makes it makes me mad
bro that make me just mad dude make me
feel like a damn just
like six badgers are climbing up and
down my spine you want to know what a
badger sounds like i'll tell you
[Music]
and let's get to the angry ones
[Music]
[Music]
that's what it makes me feel like
you know because you have companies that
don't care and now that so they're
basically you they are using the n-word
to make money
and that's that man that burns me up
it just burns me up
and i think it should burn anybody up
you know
yeah and it's kind of wild in the media
like somebody can apologize for for for
for uh saying something they shouldn't
somebody can apologize for using a
racial slur but the immediate they don't
want a apology somebody could say well
i'll i'll do better
but that's not enough for them
they want to just roast you they want to
take over they want to they want you to
burn
and that's just wild to me like
don't no matter what someone does don't
we want them to have a
don't we want them to feel
you know you want someone to feel
reprimanded
but
don't you want some don't like what if
it was your kid that did it like it's
just crazy people would
ostracize so much and just denounce
like there's you are worthless
and uh
like what do they want you to kill
yourself what do they want
do they want you to lose your own life
by your own hand by a dagger by a sword
you know
i just don't understand sometimes
because somebody's saying they'll do
better i mean it's
but i guess you know you need to believe
them
but man
and then what if and and what don't any
of these writers who write these
articles what if your kid does something
wrong one day
what if your husband your brother your
what if someone you
do you want them to be burned like that
i just don't i i don't know
and then it's wild that they'll see you
know it's like they shouldn't
we should they should just get rid of
the word
they should get rid of the word
because
you could buy it online i mean website
is mapple music somebody whatever
platform they're making money
you could go listen to it you could buy
it
maybe white people shouldn't be allowed
to buy
stuff with the word in it
because if you sell somebody enough
produce
you know when sometimes a strawberry
rolls out their mouth you can't be
shocked
but you're the one vending it to them
and i'm not saying that's the case in
this instance exactly i'm not saying
that but i'm saying that that's a real
thing
you know and i think there's a lot of
people out there of color who feel the
same way who are just tired of
the music that's like you know
kill these n words and all this [ __ ]
it's just it's
i don't know
and look
i'm just a white person so i only have
my experience
you know i grew up around a lot of black
people i used to be in a group called uh
nfl
and i can't say the whole name of the
group but i can say for life
um
dude i used to ride my bike in
in the school in the morning
and johnny smith and the boys they would
come and jump on my bike
and they would call me to a bus when i'd
come in they would call me the n-word
bus hey here comes the n-word bus and
they would all pile on my bike
and i'd be sitting there just rolling
just a damn i mean literally the
basketball team deep
and now we just you know man dude my
quads was beefy son
my quads was
beefy you know what i'm saying
damn chicka full
you know it
and they would call me the n-word bus
here come the n-word bus
and my parents didn't say it
you know
my dad said it one time a black guy
stabbed him with a screwdriver and he
said it
so i'll be honest but
um
i don't know man some of you know it's
it's just like there's just a lot of red
tape out there but then look
that's only my perspective and i'm not
saying that it's right but i don't want
to feel like i can't
think and talk about it um
because i also know that it's a hurtful
word
you know uh
but i also know that
the media just there's no court of law
there's just
they there's no examination of that kind
of thing of
of what was going on
you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you